in the early hours of a Sunday model
Julie Ferrara is on an urgent mission
if these goals are adopted they're in
jeopardy to be euthanized it's that
simple
Julie is the founder of light Long
Island Greyhound transfer a volunteer
group that helps move dogs from the
track into homes right now we're driving
to get six very lucky dogs we don't pick
the dogs most people if you said I'll
pick a dog they would go by aesthetics
color we don't allow that we only go by
personality these dogs have traveled
south from a New Hampshire dog track to
be placed with families on the East
Coast
the dogs are given a quick walk before
being transferred to the van for a trip
to a grooming shop women all volunteer
group is waiting for okay we have six
it's a small low but I think it's good
it's little candy she's uh a little
scared but she'll be okay I had hopes
watched the dog they don't know glass
there's dogs and there's grey hair it's
just very very different because of the
track training that they know nothing of
homework the first time she's seeing her
reflection she's like this is everything
is new it's like a it's like a baby it's
like a it's like a baby it really is
these dogs stay in cages for long
periods of time the only time they let
it out is when they have to relieve
themselves or for racing which is only
about twice a week at three or four days
so basically they're in cages for two
three four five years
of their life the volunteers quickly go
to work getting the dogs ready for the
new owners feeding shampooing and D
ticking this is a volunteer run
organization they get up in the middle
of the night two three four o'clock in
the morning to be there to help us wash
walk feed we couldn't do it without them
we could not do anything without the
volunteers
lemonhead was supposed to go to a foster
home but Holly cloak is one of the
regular volunteers decides to adopt her
and give her a permanent home she
absolutely fell in love with that goal
my husband said oh we have to do it in a
very serendipitous caption and she's not
spoken for Shawn is serendipity right
oh she's loving that maybe maybe you'll
change your mind you won't take this is
what happens our foster dogs don't make
it too far into foster care they want in
w-well Nilan Greyhound transfer we have
our best customers right here
the dogs are once again loaded into the
van this time for a visit to the vet
where they're examined and spayed or
neutered after that it's on to be
adopted the biggest myth is that these
dogs are nervous hyper high-strung
totally totally wrong that's our we call
them 45 mile an hour couch potatoes they
appreciate what you give them
Tuesday is Adoption Day
families and dogs file in and the
paperwork is filled out I'm putting a
copy of your adoption agreement right
into your folder after the checks are
written and new tags issued the adoption
is complete
lemonhead is now officially part of the
family and she's going home for the very
first time